okay let's try the three three one area
code caller from three three one who's
there oh damn on from the Chicago area
hey Dan and just to check we're not on
Bluetooth or speakerphone right just
look at off my question for you with
some of the reasons was that real Cana
has been getting but some of his work
with Bernie and stuff I was just
wondering what do you think about the
prospect of him as a VP candidate for
2020 either behind Bernie Sanders if
Bernie Sanders happens when the
nomination or even behind somebody else
that's a little bit more establishment
it's kind of way yeah I mean look I I
know you're never a little bit I've had
him on the program before and we've
exchanged some some messages I love his
politics
I think he's doing amazing stuff I just
am not really ready yet at this point to
think about running mates I think the
question question one is who are the
contenders going to be for the top of
the ticket and then we can start to sort
out VP I mean personally I think he's
great I I think that he would be
fantastic now I've not done an analysis
of sort of what how matched up with whom
would he be a good fit or a less good
fit or whatever else but sure I mean he
his politics are cutting edge in terms
of being right on the forefront of a lot
of the stuff that I as a Social Democrat
I'm talking about all the time
fair enough all right I think some big
fan of the show thanks for taking my
call okay thank you for calling in
really appreciate it going to go to a
break that's all the time I've got sorry
to everybody who I didn't have time for
but we will take calls again I'll take
calls again on a live stream soon we'll
take a quick break and be back after
this with the audience questions